this work is literally explaining the
way the human brain functions to keep a
human being alive and so if you need to
go to the science route it's there for
you if you need to go more of the
spiritual route it's there for you but
in the end the only thing matters is how
do you feel today and if the answer is
not great in whatever way shape or form
then this is your life isn't it worth
just replacing your fear and your anger
with curiosity
[Music]
welcome to episode 110 of the Michaela
Peterson podcast this episode is with
Nicole sacks Nicole Sachs is a speaker
writer podcaster and psychotherapist who
has dedicated her work and her practice
to the treatment of chronic pain
she's a faculty instructor at the Omega
Institute The Art of Living retreat
center and author of the meaning of
Truth Embrace Your Truth create your
life I wanted to speak to Nicole because
my family has been through a lot in the
last five years in particular and I've
been learning what I can to help them
quick update on that things are much
better now and these podcasts the next
four of them I believe were recorded
when things were really really really
not good so if you guys are worrying
about us
we're good I think the Petersons are
back in the game finally for the first
time in maybe three years
I had someone reach out and tell me that
Nicole had really helped her with
chronic fatigue and fibromyalgia so this
episode is about trying to treat that
kind of thing psychologically I hope you
enjoy
[Music]
Nicole sacks welcome to my podcast thank
you happy to be here
I'm excited to talk to you I was
referred to you by
somebody on Instagram who said you were
the go-to person for trauma stuck in the
body and how to relieve that so I
thought that would be fascinating to get
into could we just start off by you
giving a brief background about who you
are and what you do sure so my name is
Nicole Sachs I am originally a
psychotherapist that's how I sort of
started this whole journey because I was
in private practice for many years I no
longer am
um but actually if we're going to be
really honest I started this journey as
a patient of chronic pain because when I
was 19 I was diagnosed with a condition
called degenerative spondylolisthesis
which is a severe abnormality of the
lower spine
and that was delivered when I was 19
after my let's say my back went out
that's the most easy way to describe it
um when I was a freshman in college and
so I was carted home and I was subjected
to all the tests and this this was this
severe abnormality was found which is
that they gave me a pretty dark
diagnosis
um no travel no Sports
um very um strict sleeping positions no
more than one hour in a bouncy car
pretty much for the rest of my life at
19 so that was kind of harsh and of
course the biggest one was the
likelihood that I would have a
biological child was slim to none
because the weight of the baby on the
front would put up put so much stress on
my lower back that it could send me into
the kind of incident that would be um
irreparable and I could end up in a
wheelchair so this was the prognosis at
19.
oh my God I had no idea that's
terrifying oh yeah I mean it's it
defines your life at that point and um
so essentially you know I I look at this
when I when I pan out and I look at the
big lens obviously this was all part of
my journey and what was meant to bring
me to where I am today which from what I
know about you Michaela is similar I
think you know we all use our personal
Journey as as part of the um the steps
on the path you know to where we're
going and so that's where it began
um and uh I will really make the story
short which is I traveled through my
life with a great deal of fear and
trepidation but also with an
understanding that just just out there a
little bit that life was bigger than
this and I didn't quite know how it was
going to turn out but it wasn't going to
be as simple as what they were
um prescribing uh to be my life and as I
moved through my experience I came into
the world of Mind Body medicine and
understanding about brain science and
about the nervous system about what it
does to the body to be in sustained
fight or flight and what that does to
the different systems of the body and
the my primary mentor and teacher was Dr
John Sarno I don't know if you've heard
of his work but he was the he was the
pioneer of of what I teach he was an
attending physician at the Rusk Center
for rehabilitation at NYU Medical Center
for 50 years he passed away at the age
of 94 a few years ago and so he was the
Pioneer he wrote he kind of wrote the
original theory that I took and evolved
into what I do today and he was also
originally my doctor then he became my
colleague then he started referring into
my practice and so it's it's a great
um source of Pride that I was directly
connected to him before his death so I
could have that one-on-one interaction
with this genius man and then bring his
theories to the fore and so through
doing the work and through understanding
the brain science and understanding that
I was not broken that actually we all
look different on the outside and we all
actually look different on the inside
too and just because I do have the same
severe spinal abnormality if you take my
MRI today you will see it it never
degenerated I had three biological
children and exercise till the day they
were born I travel the world I play
sports I exercise I'm more fit maybe
than I've ever been I'm 49 and I just
live a completely unencumbered life
because I understand this stuff so
essentially I was in private practice
for years and my patients were like you
can't confine this to the you know the
four walls of your office it it nothing
they really encouraged me it was them
who encouraged me and so that's when I
first wrote the book
um I wrote my my first book in 2012 I
rewrote the whole thing in 2016 because
I learned so much more and that's when I
started sort of traveling the world and
teaching and running Retreats and
writing online courses and so that's
kind of where I'm at right now trying to
bring this message to the global
Community because every time I reach
another person and have them tell me
their story and Michaela the stories are
really dark I mean as I know you know
from yourself and your father chronic
illness can bring you to the darkest
places possible yeah and um I and I will
tell you that it is a regular occurrence
that I will hear from somebody from
Australia from Africa from India from
South America someone I've never met
that says I was contemplating my Suicide
I was on my couch at three in the
morning on a deep dive in Google because
I nobody could tell me what was wrong
with me or they could tell me all these
diagnoses but no one could fix anything
and I was in such severe pain or anxiety
or Panic that I was planning my Suicide
I kind of tripped over your work in this
sort of uh crazy coincidence whatever
you want to call it and I've been doing
it for six months and I am thrilled to
report I'm back to work full time I'm
getting married I'm having a baby like
these crazy stories and so I just I'm
just incredibly passionate not only for
my own body and my own world which is my
my life is my message but also just for
the way it helps people to bring this
message far and wide
okay
that was a great intro so how do you
what is your work how do you do the work
to get out of that kind of chronic pain
okay so first of all I want to make sure
to Define chronic pain correctly because
chronic pain is not just back pain neck
pain shoulder pain migraines
fibromyalgia although it is it does all
these things it's also chronic fatigue
it's also anxiety in all its forms panic
in all its forms irritable bowel disease
and stomach problems in all their forms
many skin disorders and then it can be
as gentle if you will as a lack of joy
for life and exhaustion
um an inability to see just the
lightness through the clouds it's
basically
the way every single person is in the
world you know there's no cure for The
Human Condition but when I say chronic
pain when I first started my brand I had
to pick something so I picked the cure
for chronic pain because I needed to
find a place to start but it's just so
much bigger than that so I always feel
the need on the front end to Define that
correctly because I want the umbrella to
be big enough to fit anyone underneath
it that that qualifies which is kind of
every human being even if it's just like
I said a lack of joy for life we all
deserve the whole Buffet not the scraps
under the table so okay
so having said that there are three
facets of my work so you say what is the
work
um believe do the work and patience and
kindness for yourself
so um I really think all three of those
facets are equally important so
um and I'll explain them briefly so
believe is essentially we're talking
about brain science so your nervous
system will protect you without your
permission and without asking your
opinion so your belief that something
can help you your perception of being
helpable if you will is your reality
um and I'll give an example I tell this
story sometimes I was in London I think
it was like a while at 15 years ago
let's say and I was in the midst of the
City downtown wasn't paying attention
looked the way I would assume a bus
would be coming
um and stepped into the street to cross
the street being a New Yorker I don't
follow traffic rules very well I'm sort
of you know
a little bit Brash that way and so I
just
started to walk by the time the double
decker bus whizzed past my face so I
could almost feel I felt the air in my
face and I literally almost felt like it
could brush past my nose I was already
back on the curb with no memory with no
memory and no intention of jumping back
there it is amazing what your brain and
your nervous system will do for you when
the perception of danger is detected
obviously before I had any place to have
an opinion or give permission my brain
went into action it jumped my body back
on the curb I a million percent would
have been dead it flew past me so fast
and so close and I always use that
example to just kind of hammer home the
intensity of this process and the
reflexivity of this process this is an
automatic process when we are being
protected
so when I say believe there and and I'd
say the law the largest part of my work
the biggest body of my work is to help
people believe which is why my podcast
is focused so much on success stories
and on interviews and on real-time heels
which is something I do where I do a
cold therapy session with someone I've
never met and they tell me their story
and I literally in real time work with
them so people can see how this works
and I I do all this stuff on the regular
so that's available to anyone who's
interested
I spend so much time helping people
believe because our fear and our
resistance to this process is part of
the nervous system protecting us because
the brain and the nervous system
perceive our stored trauma and our
repressed emotional world as a greater
Predator than our physical pain
conditions or state of being that makes
sense right so like let's say for
example you have
capital T trauma let's just take it to
the best the biggest extent capital T
trauma abuse neglect
um being raised in a wartime situation
anything that is extremely traumatic the
memories of that and the reliving of
that are perceived by your nervous
system as much more dangerous than a
migraine or fibromyalgia or anything
that makes you stay small and quiet and
lay down and stay away from the world so
it will keep you there in a quite loving
and protective way
until we can make our systems aware that
it's safe to feel these things and of
course it's not always safe but there's
work to be done which is in the second
facet of do the work there's work to be
done to convince this system that
protects us without our permission that
that we can feel that we can be with our
experiences once that happens and this
is why the work can be rather miraculous
if you deign to use that word
the nervous system is like a switch when
you Flip Flip from fight or flight to
rest and repair systems go into
equilibrium remarkably quickly because
in many ways we are incredibly similar
to the animal world so if you look at
like a um a herd of gazelle they'll be
grazing they'll be at the watering hole
the Predator is introduced The Lion
walks onto the Savannah the whole herd
goes up the ears go up they start
communicating with each other everyone
is tense they're ready to flee and let's
say it just casually keeps walking maybe
it just fed or whatever as soon as it's
out of energetic range the whole herd
usually shakes it off they go back to
grazing they don't run 50 miles just in
case it comes back that's not the way
our animal brain works and that's the
part of us that is protecting us even in
our evolved human State and so
once we flip that switch once we allow
the brain and the nervous system to
understand that this stuff we've
experienced experienced although
traumatic although incredibly painful is
safe to feel and to be with and that we
can do that
the pain signals stop firing this is why
people have these incredible
Transformations you know I have clients
regularly who are in motorized
wheelchairs or are bed bound for more
than a year like really long time that
are now running marathons I mean I'm not
joking this stuff is insane in terms of
the Transformations so I don't want to
keep going if you have questions but
that's the part yeah go ahead I do um
how do you convince somebody who's been
in chronic fight or flight or chronic
pain for years that they can calm down
because that's kind of what you're
saying right yeah you're asking an
excellent question just like throwing me
these uh these softballs because you
can't you can't because it's the nervous
system and it's the same thing that's
took me off the curb in London that's
why we do the second thing which is we
do the work
because no one can calm your nervous
system down but you I can talk you into
belief or I can talk you into suspension
of disbelief I can bring you to a place
where you're open
but nobody can do the work for you which
is another really unfortunate part of
this that people can feel really angry
about because it's way I often say my
work is simple but it's not easy meaning
what I'm about to explain to you today
Michaela is not going to blow your mind
and it's simple it's it's pretty simple
but the reason it's not easy is because
it takes consistent patient work with
ourselves to bring the nervous system
which has the mentality of let's say an
abused child or an abused animal like a
dog that is ready for for attack or for
flight or for fawning or for being
frozen it's ready it's at the ready so
the way you convince oneself or a person
is by doing the work and so what the
work is
um I teach a practice called Journal
speak now Journal speak is indeed a
journaling practice but it's not just a
journaling practice it's essentially
teaching you a foreign language it's
teaching you to be fluent in a second
language and the way that works is that
I teach people to go to the places that
are very triggering gently and softly by
doing it at the pace of their own
Consciousness and so essentially here's
the way it works
you make three lists
one is labeled childhood which could
also be labeled past stressors one is
labeled daily life which is anything
that is the constant onslaught of what
we're dealing with today which
oftentimes there are bridges between the
two and the third is personality because
a lot of people that are the highest
I forget lack of a better word highest
strung
um most susceptible to this kind of
um dance between the brain and the
nervous system are people who are
perfectionistic who are goodest meaning
it's very important to be seen as a good
person to be helpful people who are
rather codependent meaning like enmeshed
like I'm not really okay unless you're
okay people who are their own worst
critic
um you know people might tell you you're
okay but if you find some problems with
yourself that's going to consume you and
this energy of this kind of personality
and there's many other traits
um can really feed it's the lens through
which every experience is filtered you
know because we are who we are and so we
make three bulleted lists and they don't
have to be
um really they don't have to expose you
in any way it's like names of people or
um big categories like money or like for
me I moved a lot as a child like
constantly and so I was always making
new friends so like moving was like a
huge thing in my childhood that really
get me it got me unmoored
um so so the list is exhaustive it's
really just a brain dump to the best of
your ability you can always add to the
lists of everything that could be just a
thing and and people get especially the
personality types um get very um like I
want to do this correctly so I get a lot
of questions about the list and I'm like
no no there's no way to mess this up
unless you just choose not to do it like
it and the list also could be something
so potentially trivial as like that time
in fourth grade with the bully but that
time in fourth grade with the bully
matters you know and and it affected you
if it affected you and sometimes the
things you think are going to be the
biggest Heavy Hitters turn out to be
just playing your tapes and just your
stories and sometimes the smallest
things that you think were no big deal
open up an experience that can really be
transformative
so once people make these lists I teach
them this practice called Journal speak
which is an impolite unfettered rant a
an allowing of the inner child because I
also do a lot of work around inner child
work allowing to the end of the inner
child to scream to scream to cry to be a
victim to win the argument because even
the best parents even the most loving
parents shut us down as kids it's the
very nature of childhood versus
adulthood and every so so there's a
reservoir inside of us of Rage shame
sadness grief that has been unfelt
experiences that have not been seen and
heard
um Terror fear meaning there's so much
okay so this Reservoir exists inside of
us and what the journal speak process
does is it dips a ladle in this
Reservoir and it dumps it off every time
you do it and so the reason for chronic
symptoms is that when the reservoir I
know I'm giving a lot of information but
I'm sorry but it's like there's so much
to this it works or works okay just
interrupt me please if I'm if it's too
much
um when the reservoir hits Mac maximum
density and threatens to spill over and
inform your conscious brain the one that
the nervous system is always monitoring
for danger
how overwhelmed you are how terrified
you are how unable to manage you are how
triggered into your past trauma you are
when it hits maximum density that's when
a symptom fires because essentially the
symptom fires to protect you because it
is a protective mechanism if you can
feel your fibromyalgia your migraine
your back pain your your shoulder pain
if you can give it meaning if you can go
to the doctor if you can obsess on it
what was going on over here calms down
you stop thinking about it because you
only have the capacity to think very
seriously about one thing at a time and
so there's a distraction it is a
distraction it is a protective
distraction and it freaking works
because as soon as you are attending to
your health which without our health we
have nothing we all know that and as
soon as you're attending to your health
or your pain which will get your
attention just like this before anything
else
these
mental tumult this mental tumult over
your unresolved stuff it lays down it
really works I mean if you start
thinking about it in yourself we all can
come to understanding how it really
works and so essentially what this
journal speak is doing is gently and
systematically for 20-minute sessions at
a time followed by a 10-minute loving
kindness meditation so it's a 30 minute
practice
dumps a a ladle out calms us down and
through repetition and practice what
ends up happening and I have 20 years of
experience to the most crazy
Transformations the stuff over here the
distraction stops happening it people
often say It's Magic and I'm like it's
not magic it's brain science but it
feels like magic when it stops happening
because you can't believe that just
unearthing the stuff and sitting with it
makes migraines go away it's migraines
are so physical they make you throw up
they make you blind and and another
thing that's like kind of amazing about
my ability to teach this is I have
gotten everything
everything I've been treating people for
over 20 years I got it all I had the
migraines I had the fibromyalgia I had
because because it would run through me
almost like my body needed to show me
how to teach it's been amazing and I am
a person who is chronic pain free in
across the board because chronic pain
is an epidemic of fear and meaning
chronic pain isn't about the pain it's
about the fear of the pain it's about
the anticipation of the pain that sends
the nervous system into this fight or
flight leaves it there and then creates
it's it's it's it's an unfortunate
vicious cycle
and uh and I'll just throw it in there
so then we can open it up for questions
with the patience and kindness which is
the third aspect it's just so integral
because we are not kind to ourselves we
are not self-compassionate we beat the
[ __ ] out of ourselves at every turn
that's what we do and that continues to
dump in the reservoir and it keeps the
system going and so I do a lot of work
on inner child work and on
self-compassion not hippy-dippy
self-love I'm talking real solid I am
here with you as if you would be with a
friend so that's that's the overview
five years ago I would not have believed
any of that at all
but after I stopped taking medication so
ssris specifically
and started ex because that really put a
kind of a wall up or numbing on all of
my emotions which I didn't realize until
afterwards but when I started
experiencing these
emotions properly I realized that if I
didn't experience them if I just kind of
shut them down that it would cause pain
right and I was like that's amazing so
if you you know if you're in a horrible
situation
and you don't cry you don't experience
grief you know my arms hurt I get like
yeah spots on my arms that feel like
somebody's pushing on them yes it's like
oh that's what that was you know it's a
little bit odd to have an autoimmune
disorder and then
to also have emotional things impact you
physically and I guess it's more obvious
if you think about a rat in a cage
that's being stressed yes they're going
to physically show that right they're
going to lose hair and things it's going
to physically impact them but
I wouldn't have believed it five years
ago especially not for something as
serious as you know fibromyalgia or
chronic pain
well I completely empathize with that
there are I mean what to me is the most
um amazing expansive part of the human
experience is there are tons of things
that you could I that you could say I
wouldn't have believed six months ago I
wouldn't have believed six days ago you
know I I I'm just gonna throw it in here
just because it's timely one of my very
very dear friends died
um in the Miami building collapse this
week oh my God and it has been so sorry
I thank you and it's been absolutely
consuming me but because I'm so in tune
with my mind body system and the way it
moves through me I'm literally feeling
how my grief and how my anger and how my
shock is moving through my body and it's
it's like
I I it's it's an experience that I had
not had and I could have explained it I
could have speculated on it a week and a
half ago but today I feel it differently
so what's amazing to me is the way we
evolve constantly and if we're just open
if we're just open to unders to
understanding that that we don't know
everything
if we are just open to that that's for
sure it can be
a much more
um educational experience being alive
and so I I empathize that you didn't
understand this five years ago or you
wouldn't have been open to it but that's
what's amazing about this human journey
is like if we can just stay willing
it keeps informing us
okay so then I'm gonna ask this this is
kind of the same thing I already asked
but
my mom is
my mom had cancer and she did she's in
remission and whatever she tapped into
when she thought she was going to die
has really helped her expression express
emotions I'm gonna just stumble through
this express emotions and try and like
let go of almost what she couldn't
control and
um she did that partly through a a
partly through religion but whatever
she's done has completely changed how
she reacts to fear and stress and and
all those things
this episode is brought to you by
grass-fed beef organs by ancestral
supplements ancestral supplements makes
New Zealand sourced nose-to-tail organ
Meats bone marrow and beef organs in
simple convenient gelatin capsules
traditional peoples Native Americans and
early ancestral healers believe that
eating the organs from a healthy animal
would strengthen and support the health
of the corresponding organ of the
individual for instance the traditional
way of treating a person with a weak
heart was to feed the person the heart
of a healthy animal similarly eating the
kidneys of a healthy animal was believed
to support urinary ailments and overall
Kidney Health pancreas was fed to people
with digestive problems and spleen was
fed to people with immune and blood
deficiencies our early ancestors knew
this which is why their traditional
diets included the frequent and
nourishing consumption of nose to tail
organs visit
ancestralsupplements.com to see what
they can do for you ancestral
supplements putting back in what the
modern world has left out I hope you
enjoy the rest of this episode how
would you start a conversation with
somebody who you think could be helped
by this but isn't there like isn't ready
to believe that is there something you
can do that can maybe open them up
it's an interesting question because it
gets into spirituality and it gets into
Readiness what is true Readiness
um but I'm going to answer it anyway but
my my initial knee-jerk reaction is
people become ready and when they become
ready that's when they open and when
they open that's when things can come in
like your experience of feeling pain on
your arms alleviate when you felt your
feelings opened you to something that
you could never have been convinced of
and so that that's my my knee-jerk
reaction but but I think I feel like I
can I can answer that a little bit
better
which is my contention is that
desperation leads to surrender and
surrender leads to openness and truth
and so what I do for people
um let's say friends right so people who
are not hiring me
um professionally that are just people I
love dearly who I watch suffer
I stay close not too close I Stay open I
become I hold space for their anger or
their you know they people love to kind
of give me the side eye and go oh I'm
getting the back surgery and I go then
that's what you're gonna do you know
like so what for it's kind of like
what's the sound of one hand clapping
like I don't push back I just stay
really centered in what I know so I'm
not going to say what I believe Michaela
I'm gonna say what I know and when I can
stay centered in what I know and hold
space for people to get desperate enough
to surrender that's what I do
[ __ ] okay all right you know what I
thought it was gonna be I thought it was
gonna be something like that because I
was thinking back to when I was like
sick and really stressed and suffering
and
there wasn't anything anybody ever said
to me that suddenly switched something
on it was all like pain and suffering
and then slow realization more openness
you know what you said so that's too bad
because it can be frustrating seeing
people but I want to say I agree with
you in it trust me there's no one more
frustrating than me especially with my
freaking children okay so I have a 13
year old an almost 17 year old and an
almost 19 year old and these kids are
living a human life so they'll be
stressed and they'll have like things
like stomach things or like you know my
daughter's a dancer and she'll get like
foot pain and oh my foot you know and
all I want to do is be like let's feel
your feelings and they just want to be
like screw you so I yeah yeah there's
trust me I empathize with that so
tremendously but here's another thing I
want to say because I always bring it
back to the brain science because it's
the capital T true yeah
we don't have a choice but to listen to
our fear-based nervous system until
there's a second option so people that
you see in that level of resistance are
it's like I have such compassion for
them because they're in option one and
there's only option one for them because
they have not yet seen another option
but someone like your mother brought to
the brink of her mortality got open to a
second option and so it's like I almost
feel like energetically because even if
you're not a spiritual person you must
believe in energy it's it's the theories
of Relativity it's Einstein it's energy
Theory it's quantum physics it's true
that we are all Just Energy and
everything in this society and in this
world and in The Human Experience is an
energy exchange and so what I do when
I'm with a person like that is I I just
Center I do a lot of meditation as well
it's just a personal practice and I
Center myself in my compassion for their
predicament because they don't have a
choice when they are in option one which
is the nervous system is locked into
protecting them which is an ideological
as well as a physical experience
do you know what I'm saying like your
mind will be closed if your nervous
system thinks that feeling this stuff or
opening yourself to this stuff is too
damn dangerous
so that becomes an ideological paralysis
that I can just sit in compassion for
that person and I do watch people open
all the time
okay I'm gonna try to get around this in
a way you can tell me if this just
wouldn't work but are there like is
there any type of scientific paper that
you could send to somebody who
at least believes fully in that type of
information then that could trigger
their openness it's a great question I
mean it's I'm not a scientist I'm not a
medical doctor so my credentials are I'm
a psychotherapist I'm a licensed
clinical social worker I've done done
other
um foundational training
um trauma informed that kind of stuff
but that's the extent of my experience
having said that Dr sarno's colleagues
and the greater medical world are doing
studies all the time and this body of
work is growing and I'm on an
international list serve where people
are posting their papers
so so yes and it's not going to make a
freaking difference like I I can't tell
you how often I I could bring so I once
had a meeting with one of the top
doctors at Mount Sinai in New York and
he said he could get me in front of
grand rounds and he was really open he
was really a cool guy he just was was
able to see the big picture
and I I created an annotated
bibliography of all these different
studies that are really statistically
significant studies
um and they rejected me they wouldn't
let me come to ground rounds so
um I just I I
stand in belief that the world is
changing that the pandemic helped us
with this that just consciousness
and just the evolution of human thought
helps us with this that it will keep I
will be invited more and more it's just
we're we're in a space of change and
flux and I have to be patient
well I hope you're right okay so so some
more some more questions then okay um so
I I've learned how and I think I'm this
might be wrong but I think I have an
easier time releasing emotion now
as a female than a male at least that's
what I've seen from and talked about
with like males around me about this
kind of emotional release so I've seen
men around me get really stressed out
about something and then they don't seem
to have a switch like I have built where
I can feel it cry a bunch and then feel
that relief and it doesn't feel
appropriate for me to be like maybe you
need to have a cry because they're like
I can't right so are there things you
use more specifically for men to allow
them to feel that type of emotion yeah
you know I think that you're what you're
saying is absolutely right on that um
culturally we have created Norms we
haven't created them we're just born
into them that um make certain feelings
and certain emotive processes safer for
a woman than for a man or people who
identify as female versus male and um so
once again it's sort of similar to the
how can you convince someone question
yeah it all comes down to each person
making hard choices so oftentimes I say
about this work this will never be a
top-down communication process of
healing meaning you're never going to
turn on your TV and have the big Pharma
commercials talk about don't take this
pill feel your feelings you know you're
not going to go to your orthopedic
surgery consult and have them say Hey
listen back pain doesn't actually make
pain go and back surgery doesn't make
back pain go away which by the way
largely and widely it doesn't
um they won't say that they're not going
to be saying that to you so this is a
bottom up healing approach which really
means each person him or herself has to
decide the answer to the most important
question in the world which is
how long would you like to suffer
and I can be standing in front of oh
before covid in front of a hall of a
thousand people and I'm having this talk
and I could look I look I look at all I
get the eyes of as many people as I can
and I go that's the question you how
long would you like to suffer and it's
not supposed to be a question that
insults people it's supposed to be a
question that empowers people because as
soon as you decide in your own personal
set setting in here no more
no freaking more okay with that kind of
intensity like with my what you can feel
in my energy right now no enough if you
decide that
you can transcend male and female
barriers of feeling you can transcend
your resistance and your disbelief it
must come from understanding that life
is a choice between what hurts and what
hurts worse there's no third option and
it can be applied to the most banal
stupid thing like do I want to eat this
sugary snack
I want to eat this sugary snack here's
how I usually feel after I eat it
um but it's delicious okay and so here
we are in a situation of what hurts
versus what hurts worse and I would say
on any given day I'll eat it or I won't
depending on where I am but it's but
there's no third option there's no third
option of eating the sugary thing and
feeling great because I know myself and
that's not how it's going to go so it's
either eat it because it's more
delicious to eat it and it's worth it to
me or not and and that so that's a small
and like that goes all the way on the
other spectrum of like do I have a child
or not right like do I have a child or
not
do I want to forego my own needs from
now until the day I die you know like or
can I live without having this child
like when I thought about being a mom
it was so cool and I know you're a mom
well it was so clear to me I will be
suffering in pain worse if I don't have
these children I know they're gonna
steal my soul and they're gonna wreck me
with their suffering and they're going
to like take away all my personal
autonomy I knew that I was I was old
enough to get it but I I wanted them and
so when you can align yourself with the
truth that life is a choice between what
hurts and what hurts worse and when you
can stop begging and pleading the
universe for a third option where you
can do what you want and have no
suffering attached to it that's when we
get peace that's when we can live in the
presence of our experience okay
you get it yeah I do I do kind of get
that and
what I learned over the last well I
don't know I guess 29 years
realistically but was that whole thing
the the emotions I had which was like
you know when I was little and I was
diagnosed I was confused I was angry
that diagnosed with arthritis right and
then there was a lot of confusion a lot
of anger and a lot of fear
through the medical system and
I I remember deciding in grade three
that I just wasn't going to cry anymore
it was like I'm not like I don't want to
feel that it's weak but mostly I don't
want to feel that right and that screwed
me over for a really long time and I've
only recently realized that feeling it
even though it makes everything worse
for a little bit because expressing that
emotion hurts
the relief that comes after it is so
worth expressing it yeah and it seems
like that seems obvious and it seems
simple like now that I've understood
that but
you know getting angry or getting sad or
feeling grief I think grief is a really
big one feeling grief for when things
don't go right or when you see somebody
else suffer feeling that and it kind of
lets it go for some weird reason which
is amazing really that you can be sad
and then express it and then not be as
sad what I want you to understand
Michaela is the moment before you
figured that out it hurt worse to cry
and that's the that's the thing that's
true and that's what people need to get
and that's why I I do everything I can
to release the shame connected to not
healing fast enough or five years ago or
to not you know doing things differently
till you did things differently because
the truth of the matter is it works both
ways in third grade where you decided
you're never going to cry again that was
the less painful option until it wasn't
anymore and what's really amazing if we
if we're aware okay so if we keep
ourselves awake and aware and our eyes
open when those scales tip just enough
that we can understand that staying
where we are hurts more than the
uncertainty and the fear of stepping out
when we're aware of that then we move
and I think the most painful time
actually the most painful time is when
the scales have shifted but we're not
yet aware so we're just suffering in the
in the current choices in our present
situation not understanding why does it
hurt so badly until and maybe it could
be in the form of listening to this
podcast for one of your listeners like
until something and it could be it could
be the breeze that blows past your face
like there's It's So Random something
wakes you up and your eyes open and you
go wait a second it hurts worse what I'm
doing that's why that's why it's so hard
right now and that's why some people
experience what they call an Extinction
burst which is when they start doing
this work the pain actually gets worse
they start they start um poking The
Hornet's Nest of their trauma and of
their repressed emotional world and
they're like
they're tempted to quit because like
their pain is getting worse or their
Pain's moving around so like fine my
migraines went away but my anxiety is
crippling and I say yay I'm all about
that because that means you have it on
the run and that means you are beginning
this process of healing so it's so
important to be really gentle with
yourself as you're going through it
okay so speaking of being gentle with
yourself
how do you teach people how to be kind
to themselves you have tricks for how to
be kinder to yourself or the meditations
you use or something yes the first thing
I want to say is okay so the first
important thing to understand is it is
important to be kind to yourself for
years and years it never occurred to me
that that was important I mean I I am I
I am a real reformed like what you're
seeing today is not the person of a fly
not the person that um that you would
have seen when I was 25. I was a go go
go outcome dependent I want the a
everything requires I ca I don't want
anyone to help me I can do it all myself
yeah
um for like years and years and years
probably a great deal of my chronic pain
was a result of that so um so I didn't
if you had told me so you say five years
ago you wouldn't have believed what I'm
saying if you had told me in my 20s
let's say that self-compassion was
important I would have told you to [ __ ]
off like I would have just been like
that's the dumbest that is first of all
it's for weak people yes exactly yes
second of all it's a waste of time third
of all it's like just not me like you
know how we all say that's just not me
okay so what I think the most important
thing first is for people to know this
is a real thing self-compassion is
concrete if you don't have it you are
suffering it's like it's like being
thirsty and not having water like I I
think I think people need to understand
that if you don't feed this part of
yourself this
this part of your um emotional
Consciousness I could say this part of
your heart but that's even too soft it's
it's a part of your of the emotional
energy that surrounds you if you don't
feed that you will be irritable you will
be defensive you'll be reactive you will
be you'll push people away these are
concrete things that you don't want to
do they make your relationship suck they
make your life less full and so when
Sometimes the best thing I can do is is
give that list and be like have you been
feeling that way and most people be like
um yeah and I'm saying okay then first
thing you need to know is
self-compassion is the real deal and
it's not just what for people who you
know want to live on a commune like this
is a very real thing
um so that's first thing second thing is
you know cultivating best practices like
I'm not an expert in self-compassion and
I can't reinvent every wheel so I look
to the experts like Dr Kristen Neff Neff
she is a world-renowned researcher in
self-compassion and she has practices
that I teach you know crediting her I
teach them at my Retreats because it's
just using you know it's using the tools
that have been invented but but
explaining them properly to people with
the right context in order to open them
to make everything is a practice
everything is a practice so it's like if
you wanted six-pack abs you could go to
a trainer and they could be like this is
what you do you do this you do this and
you do this and you could be like that's
very interesting if you don't do it it
doesn't matter
so like it's it's a it's it's a practice
okay
that makes sense Neff Chris okay I'm
gonna remember yeah and if you're
interested I mean I don't want to go go
on and on if you have more questions but
if you're interested I can explain to
you a little bit about Kristen's work
but I would I would yeah a bit okay so
essentially the the um kind of the gold
nugget of it is
so we are very very good as a society in
practicing compassion other compassion
yeah so what what what
um generally we do in my Retreats when
we work on this stuff is we first
cultivate what it would feel like bring
ourselves into the space of your your
best friend or your child or your dog or
something you feel very warmly to or
toward is suffering
how would you behave what kind of body
language would you use what kind of
words would you use what kind of tone of
voice would you use so we kind of come
into that space and then we say I say
now I want you to picture the last time
you really screwed something up you
really disappointed you missed the mark
you really like you messed up what was
the tone of voice what was the body
language that you use toward yourself
what were the word choices that you used
to yourself so we start to first of all
delineate between other compassion and
self-compassion and or lack of
self-compassion and we do some exercises
around
um the physical feeling like holding
fists and feeling the energy of that and
putting arms out and closing eyes and
feeling the energy of that and and just
understanding the difference delineating
between this feeling of self-loathing
and self-criticizing and self-compassion
and then it kind of culminates in what
we call a self-compassion break which is
bringing into your Consciousness a
problem that you're having okay so it's
not not super big trauma like
um for me like I'll just give an example
it could be
um
getting my daughter ready for camp and
dealing with the fact that she had real
anxiety about camp and then covid
happened and then um so now I'm worried
that she's gonna struggle and now
there's all these coveted regulations on
Camp so it's like it's an irritating
problem that gets me emotionally kind of
up there but it's not like a horrible
life-ending problem
so you bring yourself into the energy of
that and then you do what's called a
self-compassion break which is you
repeat you repeat three phrases the
first is simply it's all labeling this
hand to heart this is a moment of
suffering
that's it okay isn't it amazing though
like you feel that energy shift just
acknowledging ah
this is a moment of suffering I'm still
I'm still at the stage where just
hearing that makes me feel like snorting
which isn't like which means I'm which
probably means I'm just not there and
I'll be there in like three months but
that kind of you know this is a moment
of suffering I don't know how I could
take myself seriously and do something
like that even though I fully believe
you fully I just okay but that's so
amazing three months no but that's
amazing Michaela because here we are in
the midst of a conscious moment of
conflict like you're you're conscious
enough to know that you probably will
shift on this oh 100 so what's that's so
you're not you're not stuck in kind of
the thickness of that moment where like
you're just like okay Nicole whatever
move on that's stupid right so like
you're conscious enough to have an
observational self look I'm being a
therapist right now but you're confident
enough to have conscious enough to have
an observational self to say hmm that's
so interesting I'm observing that this
is making me skeptical or this is making
me roll my in my inner eyes okay yeah
but what's incredible is I would
um invite you to try it maybe later get
yourself into the space of something
that's really bothering you you know
your kid isn't going through what my kid
is but your kids going through something
or your dad's going through something or
somebody in your life is going through
something that matters to you and it
makes you suffer and if you can bring
this is why the in the Retreats this is
a really powerful exercise because
people are each in their own little
bubble of experience and when you sit
there in your discomfort and label it
and say this is a moment of suffering
okay you can take the hand off your
heart if that's too cheesy for you like
labeling it
being present with it so like the way
you would if someone else were suffering
and like you wanted to ignore you wanted
to see them you wanted to make them feel
seen and heard like you're not alone in
this essentially this is a moment of
suffering we need to say that to
ourselves because when we're suffering
we feel so alone even if other people
are suffering around us our own personal
hell feels very alone and so the the
um self-compassion break the first
sentence in that which is this is a
moment of suffering is an acknowledgment
is a seeing of like how we wish others
might see us or how we would be willing
to see others to acknowledge this sucks
for you right now this is hard for you
okay so maybe that can be a little bit
more palatable yeah you know what
something clicked while you were saying
that I actually I I sit with it now like
I know enough that when I'm feeling the
grief or or Compassion or stress or
something when when somebody else is
suffering I'm aware enough to say you
know what I this feels horrible right
now but it'll if I experience it it'll
go away so it's not a this is a moment
of suffering which is what I said what
me what made me slightly skeptical but I
I don't think I've been naming it I
think I've just been experiencing it and
being like it's okay to experience this
but I haven't said this is what it is
so that's not very far apart no you're
you're not going to take three months
you might take three more minutes you're
almost there okay okay okay you're so
close
um so so that's the first sentence which
is this is a moment of suffering the
second sentence is essentially
everybody suffers right it's it's just
about taking this Human Experience that
you're having and making it ubiquitous
suffering happens for every person you
know there's a line that I think is
really powerful which is never compare
your insides to other people's outsides
you know like we're so used to like
looking at other people and being like
they've got it all especially in the
world of social media and comparison and
what do they say um compare and despair
you know and so like if you don't if you
can that second sentence once you label
your moment of suffering to say everyone
suffers everyone is going through what
they're going through in their own way
and opening yourself up to like
basically being a member of the human
race
and then the third sentence is Just In
This Moment very simply what can I do
right now to be kind to myself
and it can be as simple as I'm pausing
the stupid you know social media or word
problem that's making me feel terrible
I'm going to take a walk I'm going
outside and I'm putting the sun on my
face for one minute whatever it is it
breaks the cycle of that constant
self-criticism or self-loathing or
whatever negative ugliness you're
feeling and if you do that enough that's
it cultivates self-compassion it's sort
of a concrete way to cultivate
self-compassion
okay so those are just steps people
could use to start being answered to
themselves
and also just to touch into the moment
because it's not just being nicer to
yourself it's too
feel like in sort of a cellular way how
to shift out of it because if you know
human beings are very unconscious beings
if we don't concretely shift out of
things we stay in them so it's just it's
a practice
okay that makes sense
let's see I had a whole bunch of
questions for you okay okay you you talk
a bit about chronic fatigue syndrome so
that's something I suffered from
terribly
um and then I managed to
change my diet and get off of medication
and probably start experiencing things
and I it went away thank goodness but
for people suffering from chronic
fatigue syndrome is it the same kind of
steps that you talked about before
trying to like Ladle out unfelt emotions
yes so this can be a really triggering
conversation just so I'm going to tell
you that straight up because first of
all chronic fatigue is incredibly
challenging really it's really it's a
bad one and I'm not saying that to make
anyone frightened if that's what it's
it's no harder to recover from than
anything else but the experience of it
is incredibly deflating because without
any energy to do anything it feels
impossible to take necessary steps which
is what we're trying to tell people to
do so I just want to bring connection to
that that chronic fatigue is a really
really tough one having said that the
other reason it's triggering and this
could be applied to chronic fatigue or
any diagnosis is that people get very
tied and um
connected
to their diagnosis because they have no
other choice so once again I want to say
this with complete empathy and love
because I've had almost everything has
moved through me so I get it that um
including chronic fatigue that
what I'm about to say is the truth which
is
your chronic fatigue is his back pain
his back pain is her pelvic pain her
pelvic pain is his migraines his
migraines is her irritable bowel disease
it is immaterial the way this process
shows up in one's body so that can be
triggering for people because people are
like I am a person with migraines I have
a migraine disorder this has ruined my
life don't tell me that I'm not a person
with migraines and I'm always saying
this is not what I'm saying what I'm
saying is the manifestation of the brain
science that causes the nervous system
into fight or flight that causes these
symptoms to fire
is it's it's just immaterial the way it
shows up in people so although chronic
fatigue is a certainly a thing it's
treated no differently than migraines or
back pain or knee pain and
I just know that people really get very
up in arms about this but it's just the
truth and the reason I know it's the
truth and this is where you can either
choose to believe me or not and that's
on your you know that's on your path
whatever I've been doing this for 20
years over 20 years now in my own body
and with thousands and thousands of
people around the world and I watch what
happens which is they present with
chronic fatigue
they start doing the work the chronic
fatigue lifts and they call me and
they're like I have having these chronic
daily headaches I can't get rid of them
and I say I know honey I love you it's
okay let's keep going and then they
continue doing the work and they're
unearthing more things and they're
becoming more intimate with their trauma
and maybe they're making some changes in
their lives maybe and not always but
like it happens and then they're like
it's the damnedest thing the headaches
are gone I haven't had a headache in two
weeks my anxiety is so high and I say I
know because this is what happens it's
that like until the nervous system which
I said has the mentality and the
emotional ability to understand as a
five-year-old child who's been abused
because it's it's a primitive system we
have to just stay with it consistently
and kindly until and and eventually all
these things that move through you which
by the way this doesn't happen to
everyone but eventually it passes and
then you become a person who simply is a
human living a human life I'll get a
headache it's not like I never
experience pain it's just don't
experience fear with it so when I have a
bad headache I don't think I'm always
going to have a bad headache I think
today was a lot and this is going on and
this is going on and there are things
going on that I can't even possibly know
what's going on and I practice
acceptance sometimes I take two Advil
like I'm not like completely against the
medical model whatever you know do
whatever is you do
and then like I allow it to pass I feel
what I need to feel I'll jump to my
journal speak practice I'll talk to my
therapist I'll I'll go to a meeting or
whatever and then it passes so it's
really so the answer to your question is
it's really all the same stuff
okay why would it manifest so
differently in people
this is where we have to open to the
mystery of the human brain so um you
know there's a cliche and I don't know
what percentage we're up to in 2021 that
you we only the best scientists in the
world only understand six percent of the
brain and I don't know what percentage
we're up to but it's not high probably
not six yeah it's it's somewhere but I
have no idea okay
so the way I can explain this best is
think about the phenomenon of adrenaline
so if a baby is trapped under a car a
parent in that moment will have the
capacity to lift the car it's been
documented scientifically many times
it's an adrenaline response it is a it
is a short period of superhuman strength
that is enacted by a flood of cortisol
and adrenaline based on real panic and
need to preserve life that allows the
brain to allow the body to lift a car
and you and I both know we could go
outside right now with all our best
intentions and there's no freaking way
you're going to lift a car so this is
truth okay what I'm saying is truth in
that same fashion the brain and the
nervous system can perceive in each
person the place in your body and in
your system that it will be believed
that it will be enacted upon now
sometimes I believe this has to do with
a structural abnormality I do have did I
have spondylolisthesis my MRI is jacked
like if if you show my MRI to an
orthopedic surgeon who doesn't know
about my work they go pale they don't
know what to say to me it looks really
gross I've seen it I have I have a
vertebrae that's shattered and replaced
with scar tissue I have two vertebrae
that sit on top of one another without a
disc I have stress fractures above and
below I look mutated it doesn't affect
me at all except for a couple
physiological connections to spondy
which is that I have almost no
flexibility in like I can't touch my
toes I can get down to like mid calf
because it's just it's just a structural
and it's very hard for me to sit up
straight like when I meditate I need to
sit up against a wall or something
because it's I have weakness I I have
like it's very mild but except for those
two things which are just structural I
have no pain ever ever ever and so what
I'm saying is the pain I believe
I had a childhood it was not horrifying
but I had a very stressful death by a
thousand paper cuts kind of childhood
um that needed to be expressed that by
19 had reached critical mass and this is
where my you know the buck stopped with
this with this place in my back and then
when I went for the MRI of course it was
totally reasonable that this would be
the reason for my pain and off we go
not everyone gets a finding there's
really no finding with migraines or
fibromyalgia or irritable bowel usually
you know there's it's so it's so it's
it's it's it's it's just this is where
we have to just kind of release
ourselves to the mystery because I don't
know why it goes some people seem to
find a reasonable place you know that
that story I told you is reasonable
sometimes there isn't
okay well that's very interesting
I've like through trying to heal me and
through my family being sick I've
there's just so many factors that come
into play and they all seem to matter
which is crazy right at the beginning I
pretty much put myself into remission
with diet and was like Diet is
everything right because that's what
changed my life and then
you know my family members got sick and
I started suffering again it was like
well I seem to be more sensitive to food
how is that possible you know like like
oh there's more to it than this so then
it was like oh sleep matters wow that
was mind-blowing and it was like oh
exercise actually does improve your life
right and when you're cripplingly
depressed and someone tells you to go on
a treadmill you're like [ __ ] you that's
not gonna help and it was like oh
exercise matters and now it's like oh
you're
you know your experience of emotions can
make you sick which is crazy and I think
I I learned a lot about that when my mom
had
cancer and
through all the scientific studies we
looked at it was like she's going to die
and that's what everybody said
and then she had surgery which also
almost killed her and then she
even though it wasn't supposed to work
she like found God became okay with
something something switched and you
could see how she interacted with people
and it was like and she was she knew
when she was going to get better and
then she got better
it made no sense and so I don't know man
well no I actually want to say something
about this and I don't know how you're
going to feel about it but I'm going to
say it anyway I'm not saying
that diet wasn't important and I'm not
saying that sleep isn't important and
I'm not saying
I'm I don't discount any of it and I
care about my diet and I care about my
sleep but in my opinion all of those
things are simply vehicles to move your
nervous system from fight or flight to
rest and repair all of them so if you
believe diet now diet does matter so I'm
not discounting it but if you believe
Diet Works and you do the diet and it
works because it's also part of the diet
the only thing that matters to your
brain and your nervous system when it
comes to creating physical illness or
exhaustion is safety if you believe you
are safe just like the herd of of
gazelle once safety is registered
through the system
there is no reason for the system to be
inflamed and once inflammation is
reduced which is very quick once we are
in a space of safety everything goes
like and it falls into place and so
that's why I believe it was like one
thing for you and then it was another
because all of these are Vehicles toward
the ultimate source of human health
which is the state of the brain and the
nervous system and if we feel like we
can operate in optimal physical health
and if you study the brain science of
what happens when a person is in
sustained fight or flight
digestion shuts down okay yeah um the
first thing that happens is digestion
shuts down why because when you're
running for your life you shouldn't be
hungry or have to go to the bathroom you
know like it just makes tons of sense
you know um circulation and respiration
go up that's why we feel anxious that's
why we feel like we can't get a deep
breath because our body is trying to
help us fight flee freeze or survive in
other Fashions and so when that neces
when that necessity is eliminated by
whatever means we're doing it that's
when we start feeling free and healthy
okay that makes sense to me that makes
sense to me I hopefully this podcast can
help people I think you have to be at a
certain
at least I had to be at a certain level
of
openness even to consider emotions had
anything to do with my well-being which
seems silly looking back on it but I was
very
science oriented and if there wasn't
hard evidence in a scientific
peer-reviewed paper then it wasn't true
and now I have no idea what's true
anymore which is the best place to be
but here's here's what I want to say
here's what I want to say to people out
there who might be listening to this
with like super rolling eyes and like
continuing to like turn it off but then
not and like being tempted to get rid of
us okay so I'm speaking to you
speaking to you who wishes they would
turn it off but they can't
um
this is your life
this is your precious life
if you believe in reincarnation if you
believe in whatever that's great but
this is your life that you get to be the
specific you with your children and your
loved ones and your job and your
self-esteem and your beautiful moments
okay this is yours
what's it worth to you
is it worth opening your mind just a
little bit because although science is
what you said you needed this work that
I'm discussing with you is more
scientific than surgery
this work is literally explaining the
way the human brain functions to keep a
human being alive and so if you need to
go to the science route it's there for
you if you need to go more of the
spiritual route it's there for you but
in the end the only thing matters is how
do you feel today and if the answer is
not great in whatever way shape or form
then this is your life isn't it worth
just replacing your fear and your anger
with curiosity replacing your resistance
to something with just saying I wonder
because once you do that your body
becomes your proof just exactly what
you've been saying this whole podcast
Michaela the reason you're a Believer is
your body has been your proof once we
once we live a lived experience of
something it's very hard to unlive that
and so that's the way I get people to
heal I say just give me a month I tell
people to take the 28 day challenge of
doing my work and I say note how you
feel today
and there's a video on my YouTube
channel called the 28 day challenge I
say note how you feel today this is what
you do every day for 28 days note how
you feel at the end and decide if this
is a worthwhile practice for you that's
worth it even a skeptical person could
give it a month-long shot yeah
okay on that note if people want to find
out more about this or want to follow
you online where that where should they
go
so um okay I have a podcast which airs
every Friday called the cure for chronic
pain with Nicole sacks LCSW tons and
tons it's like I think I've been doing
it for two or three years and I've never
missed a week so just tons of free
information there with like case studies
and scientific you know conversations
with doctors and real-time heels which
is this therapy I do like right there
with people I don't have never met
before and so like it's really like kind
of awesome to be in the in the room with
that so there's that
um there's my brand is the cure for
chronic pain so I have a YouTube channel
called the cure for chronic pain I have
an Instagram where I put out new stuff
every day which is where you found me
um at Nicole sacks LCSW I teach Retreats
so um depending on when this airs I will
be at the Omega Institute for August 1st
through the 6th and that will be
something where we have five days with
myself and just this dream team of
instructors that it's really really
changes your life I must say it's a real
transformative experience to be be a
live Retreat so there's that I have two
online courses it's called one's called
freedom from chronic pain one's called
freedom from an anxious life I do a lot
of work to get information available to
people much of it is free so that they
can just begin this for themselves and
then if they need more help they can
take a course I have a Facebook
Community called journals fake Journal
speak with Nicole sacks that is a closed
group so not nobody sees what you post
except the members of the group and it's
thousands of people in conversation
about this stuff supporting one another
asking questions answering questions
um just Google my name I'm all over the
place
okay thank you very much for coming on
and talking to me that was really
interesting thanks for having me that'll
help it was really great
[Music]